Hallo, guten Abend, guten Tag. Ich heiße Aydin. Ich möchte mit Ihnen das an einem
Neskespräch führen. So erst brauche ich Ihre persönlichen Daten. Dann kommen wir
zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Sie müssen ja wissen, mit wem Sie zu tun haben. Ja klar.
Ja, okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Kevin Jäger.
Kevin Jäger. Könnten Sie Ihre Vorname und Nachname langsam bestabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Kevin K-E-V-I-N. Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Jäger. J-E, also A umlaut, G-E-R.
Herr Jäger, richtig? Genau, richtig.
Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 20 Jahre.
20 Jahre, oh. Wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 12.09.2005.
12.09.2005.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Oh, ich bin 1,80 und ich wiege zur Zeit so 69 Kilo.
69 Kilo? Okay. Wie kann Ihnen heute helfen? Was haben Sie, Herr Jäger?
Ja, also das ist ganz merkwürdig. Ich hab seit jetzt schon seit drei Wochen fühle ich mich krank und schlecht.
Und ich hab auch Fieber. Okay.
Also ja, ich hab Kopfschmerzen und ich hab auch Bauchschmerzen.
So auf der linken Seite, so oben im Bauch tut es weh.
Und ja, manchmal hab ich so das Gefühl, dass ich gar nicht gut schlucken kann.
Vor allen Dingen, ich fühle mich richtig schlapp.
Ich bin jetzt schon seit Wochen bin ich nicht bei der Arbeit gewesen, hab mich immer krank gemeldet.
Und mein Chef hat zum Glück verständet, aber ich fühle mich total, ja, krank.
Erschöpft oder Mütigkeit? Herr Kersting?
Okay. Sind Ihre Hauptbeschwerde Fieber oder Schmerzen?
Ja, also das Fieber, das finde ich schon, das ist zum Teil bis zu 39 und es wird gar nicht weniger.
Und ja, die Kopf- und Bauchschmerzen sind schon auch unangenehm, ja.
Okay. Wann sind Sie Ihre Fieber gemessen?
Ich hab das immer abends gemessen.
Gestern? Ich habe nicht gehört.
Abends, also ich hab immer abends gemessen, ja.
Okay. Wo haben Sie gemessen?
Ich hab so ein Ohrthermometer.
Okay. Bauchschmerzen links seitlich, haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, ich meine ja. Vor allem so oben im Bauch, also oberhalb vom Bauchknappel tut es so weh.
Okay. Könnten Sie Ihre Bauchschmerzen beschreiben?
Stehen, ziehen, drücken?
Es drückt, würde ich sagen, es drückt und ja, es kommt eigentlich so, ja, immer mal in so Wellen, die Schmerzen.
Es ist nicht immer gleich, sondern ja.
Wieder gerne. Nicht anhaltend?
Nee, also es hat so ein Auf und Ab irgendwie.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Wie viel, wie stark Ihre Schmerzen und Bauchschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen alle zusammen anfangen oder?
Ja, also ich hab mich mit einem Mal so krank gesühlt.
Erst dachte ich, ich kriege vielleicht so eine Grippe oder so was, aber weil es jetzt schon so lange geht, fühle ich, hab ich jetzt gedacht, jetzt muss ich doch mal irgendwie was unternehmen, ja.
Wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala sind?
Auf einer Skala null. Keine Schmerzen, zehn sehr stark Schmerzen. Könnten Sie beschreiben?
Das ist schwer das einzuschätzen. Was sind sehr starke Schmerzen? Also, sehr stark sind die nicht.
Also man kann das hier aushalten, aber es ist halt lästig. Vielleicht so in der Mitte, ich würde sagen so fünf, ne?
Ja, okay, für Kopf auch?
Ja, eigentlich beides, ja.
Haben Sie dagegen eine Schmerzmittel oder Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich mehrmals Paracetamol eingenommen.
Okay, täglich oder?
Ja, also jetzt die letzten Tage, die letzte Woche eigentlich fast jeden Tag, aber irgendwie hat es nicht geholfen.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Haben Sie selbst eingenommen oder mit Rat?
Mit Ratten.
Mit Hausraten.
Auf Rat vom Hausarzt, nein.
Hausarztrat, ja.
Nein, ich war gar nicht beim Arzt, aber das Paracetamol, das kann man ja so kaufen und da habe ich eigentlich immer ein bisschen was zu Hause, wenn man mal tatsächlich so Fieber hat oder so.
Okay, könnte Sie auch Ihre Kopfschmerzen beschreiben?
Ja, wie so Kopfschmerzen halt sind, es dröhnt halt so, aber im ganzen Kopf würde ich sagen.
Also so von der Stirn an so nach hinten, ja.
Okay, vorne.
Und ich merke, dass ich mich eben nicht gut konzentrieren kann und ja, weil die Kopfschmerzen eben da sind und so beim Einschlafen macht mir das auch ein bisschen Probleme.
Okay, verstehe Sie.
Haben Sie Erschütterung und Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß, wüsste ich ja.
Schütterfrost.
Schüttelfrost habe ich noch nicht gehabt, nein.
Obwohl das Fieber ja ganz schön hoch ist, aber das hatte ich noch nicht.
Also nachts schwitzen tue ich aber nicht, nein.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Beschwerden bei Schlafen?
Also zurzeit schlafe ich nicht gut, nein.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Luftbeschwerden oder Husten?
Nee, das habe ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Aber Husten, so etwas habe ich nicht und ich kriege auch Luft, aber das Schlucken tut mir tatsächlich ein bisschen weh.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie auch?
Ja, deswegen dachte ich ja erst, ich kriege eine Grippe, als es so mit den Schlucken anfing.
Haben Sie Halsschmerzen auch?
Nee, so richtig Halsschmerzen, so dass es kratzt im Hals, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Gibt es eine besondere Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen und Ihre Schluck oder Ihre Fieber?
Ich weiß nicht, wie gesagt, ich habe ja am Anfang gedacht, das ist jetzt irgendwie eine Grippe oder so.
Eine Grippe, haben Sie gesagt.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was der Auslöser ist.
Okay, gibt es etwas, was Ihre Beschwerden verstärkt oder lindert?
Ja, also ich bin halt so schlapp, denn ich kann eigentlich fast nur zu Hause so ein bisschen rum sitzen und fühle mich eigentlich am wohlsten.
Wenn ich im Bett lege, dann geht es mir eigentlich am besten.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen?
Nee, das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
In der richtigen Weise ist der eigentlich gut, aber zurzeit ist es nicht so dolle.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Also beim Wasserlassen auf keinen Fall, beim Stuhlgang.
Da ist mir halt aufgefallen, dass ich in der letzten Zeit verstärkt Luft brauche, dass ich so Blehungen habe.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt Gewichtverlust oder Verloren oder Zugenommen?
Oh, ich wiege mich jetzt nicht so häufig.
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich ab oder zugenommen habe.
Glaube nicht.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter einer chronischen Erkrankung?
Nee, ich muss da ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich habe so eine Sonnenunverträglichkeit im Gesicht und an den Händen.
Also wenn ich zu viel Sonne abkomme, dann wird das ganz rot und fängt an zu jucken und so.
Und deswegen, wenn das also schlimm ist, muss ich tatsächlich Cortisonsalbe benutzen.
Aber ich versuche eben, so der Sonne ein bisschen aus dem Weg zu gehen, indem ich mich eben, also lange Ärmel trage und einen Sonnen, also Schirmmütze oder so was im Sommer.
Okay.
Würden Sie eine bestimmte Diagnose festgestellt?
Nee, also man hat mir nur gesagt, das ist eine Sonnenunverträglichkeit.
Okay.
Und ja, womit ich auch jetzt schon eine ganze Weile rummache.
Ich habe so hinten eine Achilles-Szene am linken Bein. Die ist schon seit Wochen entzündet.
Und das ist sehr, sehr schmerzhaft.
Seit wann? Ich habe nicht...
Seit fünf Wochen.
Ja, ich mache das immer mal so kühl, schon das natürlich auch.
Also ich mache jetzt keinen Sport.
Jetzt in letzter Zeit sowieso nicht, falls es mir nicht gut geht.
Aber das ist sehr schmerzhaft, ja.
Okay. Welcherseits alle ganze Rücken oder? Ich habe nicht richtig festgestellt.
Nein, die Achilles-Szene.
Achilles-Szene.
Okay, okay, Achilles-Szene.
Normalerweise haben Sie nie Beschwerden früher?
Nee, das ist jetzt irgendwie neu aufgetreten.
Okay. Vor fünf Wochen.
Seit fünf Wochen habe ich... Ja, das wird gar nicht viel besser.
Okay. Jetzt haben Sie auch?
Ja, also die Schmerzen habe ich eigentlich ständig.
Ich denke mal, das ist vielleicht ganz gut, dass ich zurzeit nicht so viel laufe.
Nein, das tut wahrscheinlich dem Bein ganz gut.
Okay, haben Sie Gelenksteifigkeit oder Bewegungsprobleme?
Nein, also bis auf diese Schmerzen da eigentlich nicht, nein.
Okay. Haben Sie normalerweise andere... Ich habe nicht gefragt, welche Seite diese Achilles...
Die linke Seite.
Haben Sie andere Gelenkschmerzen oder Beschwerden?
Nee, sonst eigentlich nicht. Aber lieber Gott, ich bin 20 Jahre alt. Also das habe ich hoffentlich nichts.
Okay. Erinnern Sie sich wegen einer Verletzung oder einlicher Auslöser? Gibt es?
Ja, also bei den Beinen denke ich mal, dass ich vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben habe beim Sport.
Okay. Sonst haben Sie keine Vorerkrankung?
Naja, also ich hatte... Das war nicht so toll. Ich hatte vor zwei Jahren eine Lungenentzündung.
Lungenentzündung, zwei Jahre, vor zwei Jahren.
Aber da habe ich halt Medikamente bekommen und weiter ist es eigentlich wieder gut.
Okay, perfekt. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nie, operiert bin ich tatsächlich noch nie.
Okay. Außer Paracetamol, haben Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf eingenommen?
Medikament? Also sonst eben nur diese Salbe, diese Cortisom-Salbe.
Ja, wenn es nur Kopfschmerzen oder so nehme ich auch mal Aspirin oder so.
Okay, Aspirin. Erinnern Sie sich, welche Dosierung?
Boah, ich glaube das sind 500er.
Für Paracetamol auch erinnern Sie sich?
Also wenn ich die einnehme, ich kann gar nicht sagen, was steht denn da drauf?
Ich kann Ihnen das gar nicht sagen, was da drauf steht.
Aber es ist jedenfalls so eine Dosis für Erwachsene bei den Paracetamol.
Ja, 500er.
Könnte gut sein, ja.
Okay, sonst noch...
Nee, sonst nehme ich zum Glück keine Medikamente.
Haben Sie so eine Allergie, außer so eine Allergie oder Unversich-Probleme?
Ist bei Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unversichlichkeit bekannt?
Ja, also ich habe auch im Frühling Heuschnupfen.
Also wenn bestimmte Pollen unterwegs sind, dass ich dann niesen muss und trennende Augen habe und so.
Trennende Augen.
Sind Sie vollständig kieft?
Vollständig, das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Also ich habe zweimal so eine Covid-Geschichte da gemacht.
Und als Kind bin ich natürlich gegen alles Mögliche geimpft worden.
Aber sonst wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass ich noch irgendwelche Impfungen zusätzlich hatte.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Und letzte Zeit waren Sie in Ausland oder würden Sie von einem Insekt gestochen?
Insekt?
Also im Ausland war ich jedenfalls nicht.
Und Insektenstich ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Nee, also manchmal so ganz selten, so gelegentlich, wenn jemand sagt,
komm wir rauchen jetzt eine zusammen, dann rauche ich mal eine mit.
Aber eigentlich bin ich kein Raucher.
Okay, früher haben Sie auch nicht geraucht?
Nee, also als Kind ja sowieso nicht.
Ich habe das nie richtig angefangen.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also sehr gelegentlich.
Hin und wieder trinke ich mal ein Glas Bier oder so.
Oder wenn es mal richtig, also wenn mein Fest ist oder so, dann trinke ich schon auch mal Alkohol.
Aber eigentlich so gut wie nicht, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Meinen Sie pro Monat einmal oder?
Ja, das haut da ungefähr hin, ja.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Diese Frage.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Okay. Treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, normalerweise mache ich eigentlich schon Sport.
Ich gehe ganz gerne ins Fitnessstudio.
Aber wie gesagt, jetzt in letzter Zeit eben nicht wegen der Achillessehne.
Und jetzt mit dem Schlappi, da geht es überhaupt nicht, wo es mir so schlecht geht.
Ja, okay.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr früh gestorben.
Der hatte eine ganz dobe Schilddrüsenerkrankung.
Der hatte Schilddrüsenkrebs und ist also Mitte 40.
40? Oh, so jung.
Und der ist also wirklich nicht alt geworden.
Ja, meine Mutter lebt noch.
Die hat allerdings jetzt schon relativ früh so einen Altersdiabetes bekommen.
Okay, sonst noch gibt es andere Vorleitkrankungen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das mit dem Zucker da zusammenhängt.
Sie hat halt irgendwie so an den Augen, an der Netzhaut, da ist irgendwas kaputt.
Ablösung oder?
Ich weiß nicht, da ist irgendwas, ist da nicht richtig.
Okay, kein Problem. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war alleine.
Wie ist Ihr familiäres Zustand? Sind Sie verheiratet oder ledig?
Nein, nein, nein, ich bin noch ledig.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder? Oder haben Sie keine Partner?
Auch das nicht.
Was machen Sie beruflich? Ihr habt nicht gefragt?
Ja, ich bin noch in der Ausbildung. Ich bin in der Ausbildung zum technischen Zeichner.
Technischen Zeichner.
Herr Jäger, haben Sie Fieber, Schluckbeschwerden, Kopfschmerzen und Bauch, Oberbauch, linkseitige Bauchschmerzen, Welle vormich?
Ja, also die Bauchschmerzen mit der Bauchschmerzen habe ich ja.
Und wegen dieser Beschwerden haben Sie Insomnie und Schlafstörungen und Appetanzverlust.
Ja, so kann man sagen.
Ja.
Haben Sie noch andere Probleme?
Ich finde, es ist schon wirklich genug, was man im Augenblick so zu schaffen macht.
Ja, ja. Haben Sie gesagt Schluckbeschwerden?
Haben Sie eine Fölle und eine Halsprobleme oder Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe gemerkt, dass das hier am Hals so ein bisschen dick ist. Ja.
Okay, haben Sie Halsschwellung oder?
Ja, ja, also hier am Hals ist es ein bisschen dick, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Haarausfall oder Hautgetrocknung?
Haustrockne Haut? Also Hausfall? Nee, habe ich zum Glück noch nicht.
Und die Haut ist eigentlich eher nicht trocken, nee.
Okay.
Vielen Dank für alle Informationen, Herr Jäger.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ich will natürlich wissen, ja, was da ist.
Und natürlich habe ich auch ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen Angst, weil mein Vater eben diese Schilddrüsenerkrankung gehabt hat.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Und ich finde, dass das damit irgendwas zu tun hat oder so.
Und naja, ich meine, ich bin halt jung und ich will wieder fit werden.
Ich will wieder zu meiner Arbeit und zu meiner Ausbildung.
Und ja, was können wir machen, ne?
Ja, Herr Jäger, so erst wie Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann Blutart nehmen und dann ein paar Bildgebende-Untersuchungen machen.
Es ist so früh etwas zu sagen für Ihre Verdachtdiagnose, aber ich vermute, Sie haben Schilddrüsenbeschwerden auch.
Nach der aller Untersuchungen können wir wieder sprechen.
Okay.
Könnten Sie in Wartezimmer warten?
Wartezimmer, ja klar.
Danke.
Wenn Sie warten, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie bemerkt, es ist ein Lymphknoten im Halsbereich?
Ja, also ich habe gemerkt, dass das am Hals hier dick ist, ne?
Aber Lymphknoten nicht, ja? Oder etwas?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Lymphknoten sind.
Unter der Kiefer oder im Halsbereich?
Ja, so hier an der Seite so.
Beide Seiten?
Ja, ja.
Danke schön.
Ja, Überleitung und Erbruchung habe ich nicht gefragt.
Ah ja, stimmt, die habe ich aber nicht.
Ah ja, okay, perfekt.
Normalerweise, ja.
Ich hatte auch eine Frage.
Ja, gerne.
Gibt es in Ihrer Ungebung jemanden, der vielleicht gleiche Beschwerden hat?
Da sagen Sie was, ja.
Also noch nicht so lange.
Aber meine Freundin, die sagt jetzt mit einem Mal auch, dass sie sich schlecht fühlt, ja?
Ah, okay.
Wenn Sie verheiratet, wenn nein, haben Sie einen festen Partner?
Ja, ich wohne mit meiner Freundin zusammen.
Er hat ja gefragt, nach dem Familienstand, und ich habe gesagt, ich bin ledig.
Aber ich wohne mit meiner Freundin zusammen.
Ihre Freundin hat auch gleiche Beschwerden?
Ja, seit ein paar Tagen hat sie auch solche Beschwerden, ja.
Gleiche Beschwerden?
Ja, wir nähern uns der Sache.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Erinnern Sie eine Säckenbiss?
Wie ich das nenne?
Ja, Säcken.
Ein Säckenbiss?
Ja.
Wer hat das gefragt?
Er hat gefragt, ob ich einen Insektenstich habe.
Habe ich aber verneint.
Aber ich habe jetzt Ihre Frage so verstanden, dass ich gesagt habe,
wie nennen Sie einen Insektenstich?
Ob ich einen hatte, einen Insektenstich?
Wollten Sie wissen?
Hallo?
Ja, normalerweise Insektenstich.
Insektenstich?
Ja, Insektenstich.
Mir ist kein Insektenstich aufgefallen.
Und irgendwas war mir gerade auch gut.
Hallo, schon abends, Frau Oberstin.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Ich möchte Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich.
Vielen Dank.
Die 20-jährige Patientin, nämlich Kevin Jäger,
ist 1,80 Meter groß und 69 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient stellte sich heute wegen seit drei Wochen
bestehender Sefalgie,
Pneumatisierung,
Sefalgie,
Sefalgie, Abdominalgie
und sowie Fieberpurexie mit 39 bei uns vor.
Der Patient berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen auf einer nummerischen Skala
von 5 von 10 seien.
Der Patient klagt über Sefalgie,
Halsverdickung,
Konzentrationsstörung, Belewungen
und ja.
Das ist schon ein rundes Bild, ja.
Seine Freunde haben eine Beschwerden.
Die Vegetative-Anamnese ist bis auf Insomni und
in Appetens unaufällig.
Sie leidet.
Ja, richtig.
Er leidet.
Machen wir den Satz nochmal neu.
Ja, er leidet.
Seit 5 Wochen.
Ja.
Er leidet seit 5 Wochen.
Unter Archilisäne Schmerzen.
Linkseitige Schmerzen.
Und vor 2 Jahren eine Lungenerkrankung
oder Unterlungenerkrankung.
Die Entzündung
habe ich nicht gefragt.
Im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Aber gelitten.
Da ist noch ein Fachbegriff.
Ja.
Bronchitis oder Phenomonie.
Phenomonie, ja.
Phenomonie gelitten.
Er nehme Paracetamol 5 mg bei Bedarf.
Cortison auch eine selbe.
Warum?
Ja, gegen Sonneallergien oder gegen Sonnegewicht.
Gezicht, Rotung und auch...
Exxanthem.
Okay.
Und auch gegebenenfalls Aspirin
habe er eingenommen.
Sie rauchen nicht.
Oder sie sei nicht Raucherin.
Immer noch.
Verzeihung, ich habe nichts geschrieben.
Ich sehe auch nicht sehr nennlich aus.
Er trinkt gegebenenfalls ein Glas Bier.
Einmal pro Monat oder bei Fest.
Die Fragen nach Drogen würde verneint.
Und sie treiben normalerweise Fitness.
Aber seit 5 Wochen wegen seiner Schmerzen.
Es ist nicht möglich.
Der Vater sei wegen Traudakarsinom verstorben.
Mit 40 Jahren verstorben.
Die Mutter hat Diabetes, Melitis und Retina.
Sie hat eine frühere Allergie.
Sie reagiert auf zähnende Augen.
Ich erinnere mich nicht auf Medikamente.
Und schnupfen.
Heuch schnupfen.
Er sei leidig.
Er hatte keine Kinder.
Sie machen eine Ausbildung im Technischen Bereich.
Ich habe nichts geschrieben.
Die Anamnestische Angaben deuten am besten auf eine Entzündung.
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Was spricht denn dafür?
Es gibt eine Fieber.
Ich habe nicht gesagt Fatigue.
Ich habe auch keine Muskelprobleme.
Ich habe auch Kopfschmerzen.
Und 3 Wochen nicht.
Das ist supergut.
Auch seine Freunde.
Er hat auch eine Fieber.
Was machen Sie jetzt diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Wir werden erst körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Mutter?
Die Vitalparameter.
Allgemeinzustand.
Ernährungszustand.
Halsbereich.
Gesichtinspektion.
Bauch.
Lungen- und Herzinspektion.
Laufschwung.
Druckempfehlung.
Was erwarten Sie?
Ich warte auf eine Ausbildung.
Luft.
Ich habe keine Dialoge.
Gibt es noch eine Besonderheit?
Knoten.
Welche Knoten?
Halsknoten.
Halsluftknoten.
Ich bin auch beim Bauch.
Es kam jetzt hier über Einlendung rein.
Was erwarten Sie beim Bauch?
Normalerweise vermehrte Luft.
Knoten im Bauch.
Spleenomegaly oder Hepatomegaly.
Ich muss kontrollieren.
Was machen Sie weiter diagnostisch?
Im Labor.
Ich lasse im Labor ein großes Blutbild.
Besonders die Entzündungparameter.
B-Säge.
Ich weiß nicht Deutsch.
Eine blutdick.
Erinnerung?
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie meinen.
Untermikroskopische Erinnerungen.
Was machen Sie noch im Labor?
Nierenparameter.
Elektrolyden.
Antigen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen.
Ich habe es schon mal gesehen.
Antigen.
Antigen kontrollieren.
Das ist wichtig. Genau.
Normalerweise untermikroskop eine
Präparation machen.
Wenn sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt.
Was wäre denn differenzial diagnostisch überhaupt noch denkbar?
Normalerweise wie
als Differenzialdiagnose wie
Tonsilitis, Lungenentzündung,
Phänomonie und
manchmal Hotkinlenforma.
Denken wir.
Um Hotkinlenforma
auszuschließen.
Wie werden wir Ultraschall
dann Biopsy und
es ist Möglichkeit eine CT mit
Kontrastmittel auszuschließen.
Ja.
Gut.
Ja. Wie würden Sie denn?
Wie würden?
Nicht troffen.
Türkische wie sagen Peripherik Eimer.
Okay. Verstehe ich nicht. Blutver...
Abstrich.
Ja. Manchmal ausstrich. Ja. Richtig.
Das wäre sinnvoll, wenn wir Verdacht auf Malaria
aber in infektiose Mononukleose
vielleicht denken wir.
Lokositen zusammen eine besondere
Ja die haben doch nur einen Kern.
Mononukleose heißt sie haben nur einen Kern.
Okay.
Manchmal ich falsch erinnere.
Jetzt haben wir also.
Jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus es bestätigt sich ihr Verdacht.
Was wäre denn die Therapie?
Ja. So erst empfehle ich
Stationäraufnahme und eine Isolation machen.
Es ist manchmal wichtig.
Weil es gibt eine infektiose Problembeschwerde.
Und eine Venöse Zugang legen.
Und Flüssigkeit geben. Schmerzmittel.
Auch eine
Unterstützung können wir.
Ja. Also wir können eigentlich nur symptomatisch.
Ja symptomatisch und Flüssigkeit und Unterstützung
mit D-Vitamin C-Vitamin auch.
Es ist wichtig im Immunsystem zu stärken.
Ja. Ja. Okay. Gut.
Ja. Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden was der Patient
tatsächlich dann für Symptome zeigt und was Sie bei Ihren Untersuchungen
rausbekommen. Gut. Wir sprechen nachher nochmal
Okay. Ja. Ja. Also
Wir haben natürlich hier klar.
Also nach einer Weile war es klar dass es die
Mononukleose ist. Wissen Sie wie das auf Deutsch
auch heißt? Das hat auch eine deutsche Bezeichnung.
Was? In Sympnifiction? Mononukleose.
Ich weiß nichts. Nie. Es gibt eine
deutsche Bezeichnung und es gibt eine ganz witzige
englische Bezeichnung. Kennen Sie die?
Die Mononukleose.
Mononukleos Kern.
Ein Kern.
Es gibt zwei
allgemein gültige. Ich weiß nicht.
Im Deutschen. Meine Kollegin geschrieben. Pfeifersches Drüsenfieber.
Pfeifersches Drüsenfieber.
Das ist die deutsche Bezeichnung weil irgendwie ein
Doktor oder Professor Pfeifers das irgendwann mal festgestellt hat.
Die sehr schöne englische Bezeichnung ist Kissing Disese.
Kissing Disese normalerweise.
Weil man sich über Speichel und beim Kissen eben
man sich prima anstecken kann.
Insofern ist schon auch bedeutsam
diese Tatsache, dass die Freundin eben
die gleichen Symptome hat. Das war jetzt sehr
hilfreich, dass die Frage hier noch aus dem Plenum kam.
Gut. Ja, das ist diese Geschichte.
Wir können jetzt schon ein bisschen was zum
zu dem. Genau. Nicht Pfeiferisches, sondern Pfeiferschiss.
Das I fällt noch weg.
Pfeiferschiss Drüsenfieber. Wir haben
ja sie haben natürlich eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Sie haben natürlich auch
wenig Sprachprobleme. Aber ein paar
Kleinigkeiten gibt es schon. Und zwar
ist mir aufgefallen, dass sie
bei den Fragen
insbesondere ziemlich oft haben sie
haben zwar sehr gezielt manchmal ist ihnen aufgefallen
was auch immer. Aber das ist
ich finde auch, dass das schwer ist da Alternativformulierungen
zu finden. Aber da muss man sich ein paar überlegen.
Ja, diese Fall ein bisschen schwer. Ich glaube wegen dieser schwer
Fälle habe ich nicht richtig alle gedacht.
Das ist ein schwieriger Fall. Ja, ja. Normalerweise
nach den drei Fragen. Ich vermute
welche. Was haben Sie gedacht Schilddrüse?
Normalerweise habe ich gedacht Schilddrüse, aber nicht
Schilddrüse, weil es gibt eine erhöhte
Fieber. Normalerweise aber. Ja, ja.
Gut also. Ja.
Ich habe gerade auch M gemacht. Sie machen sehr, sehr häufig
E. E. Okay. Sehr häufig.
Ja, wir haben da schon oft drüber gesprochen. Alle machen das.
Alle machen das mehr oder weniger häufig. Sie machen das wirklich ziemlich
häufig. Okay. Und
ja, was mir dann aufgefallen ist, sie haben
dann für den Patienten eine Zusammenfassung gemacht.
Sie haben gesagt, da ist es schon
wieder bei mir selber. Sie haben gesagt,
haben Sie Kopfschmerzen und Bauchschmerzen und so. Das wäre wie eine
Frage. Aber eigentlich wollten Sie ja eine Zusammenfassung machen.
Sie wollten ja die Zusammenfassung machen. Ich fasse noch einmal
zusammen. Sie haben also Kopfschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen,
Erschöpfung.
Das ist diese wichtige Sache, dass im Deutschen das
Verb an der zweiten Stelle kommt. Ja. Und
danach ist es nämlich genauso nochmal gekommen. Ich habe jetzt
nicht mehr ganz genau den Zusammenhang drauf,
aber ungefähr so. Danach wir untersuchen sie.
Nee, danach untersuche ich sie.
Also wenn da danach steht,
dann ist das schon die erste Position. Dann muss das Verb an der zweite Stelle.
Danach untersuchen wir sie.
Das ist ein ganz, ganz häufiger Fehler. Der wird von
fast allen nicht muttersprachlich gemacht.
Aber wenn Sie es wissen, können Sie ja ein bisschen drauf achten.
Ich glaube, inhaltlich war alles sehr korrekt
wiedergegeben im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch. Was natürlich ein bisschen gemeint war,
dass sie immer wieder drauf reingefallen sind, dass es
sie und er. Ja, ich war halt ein Mann
in diesem speziellen Fall. Der Kevin ist ein Mann.
Ja, und
was ich schön fand, Sie haben ihn ziemlich oft mit Namen angesprochen.
Aber gut. Und was ich auch gut fand,
Sie haben nicht so in Ihrem Papier gehangen beim Sprechen,
sondern Sie haben ein bisschen in die Kamera geguckt.
Das ist vor allen Dingen in der Prüfungssituation wichtig,
dass Sie sich nicht in Ihren Zettel oder Ihrem Computer
vertiefen. Ja, auch so eine bekannte Sache.
Wir möchten gerne von unserem Arzt angesehen werden.
Wir möchten nicht, dass er die ganze Zeit nur auf seinen Bildschirm guckt.
Gut. Vielen Dank.
Ein bisschen Verständnisprobleme hatten wir hin und wieder mal.
Aber ich denke mal,
nicht tragisch.
Das sollte auf alle Fälle
gut über die Bühne gehen, würde ich sagen.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen am E-Arbeiten
und vielleicht noch ein paar Fragenformulierungen
sich überlegen.
Und bei der Wiedergabe, würde ich sagen,
haben Sie das ziemlich komplett und ziemlich vollständig gemacht.
Vielleicht kann man noch so ein ganz kleines bisschen
eine Einleitung machen, wenn man dann sagt, ja,
tatsächlich ergab sich, dass der Vater schon mit Mitte 40
verstorben ist. Was mir aufgefallen ist,
die Mutter leidet, das hat er ja ausdrücklich gesagt,
an Diabetes Meritus 2. Er hat ja gesagt,
obwohl sie noch nicht so alt ist, hat sie schon Alterszucker.
Wer weiß, wie dick sie ist. Und letztlich noch,
der Beruf. Wenn Sie nicht verstehen, welcher Beruf das ist,
fragen Sie nach. Ja, ich habe geschrieben,
aber danach habe ich nicht gelesen.
Er hat gesagt, er hat gesagt, ich bin in der Ausbildung
als technischer Zeichner.
Technischer Zeichner, ja, okay. Ich denke mal,
den Beruf gibt es auch heute noch trotz aller Computertechnologie.
Also das ist tatsächlich im Originalfall,
ist das nämlich der angegebene Beruf.
Und ich glaube, das ist inzwischen so wahrscheinlich ein aussterbender Beruf,
weil das heute alles von digitalen Medien übernommen wird.
Aber ja, wie gesagt, fragen Sie ruhig nach.
Also wenn ich heute höre, was für
Berufe es gibt und wie das beschrieben ist,
da braucht man nur mal die Stellenanzeigen von einer großen Zeitung
anzugucken. Da steht man ja eigentlich da und sagt,
boah, was könnte das denn jetzt sein? Weil das
Berufe sind, da kann man nicht so richtig verstehen, was die Leute
jetzt machen. Gerade für uns alte Leute,
alles was im digitalen Bereich ist, ich habe keine Idee,
was die Leute den ganzen Tag tatsächlich tun. Ich habe auch nicht so richtig
die Vorstellung, was meine eigenen Kinder den ganzen Tag machen, muss ich sagen,
bei ihren Berufen. Es ist tatsächlich ein bisschen schwierig,
sich mit dem Beruf
irgendwie was vorzustellen. Aber manchmal ist es ja
wichtig, weil es auch einen Hinweis
geben kann, woher die Beschwerden kommen. Wenn jemand
zum Beispiel den ganzen Tag am Computer arbeitet, ist es ja vielleicht
denkbar, dass der eben was, was ich Augenprobleme hat oder
Nackenprobleme, weil er ständig eine schlechte Arbeitshaltung hat.
Oder gerade die Leute, die in der Corona-Zeit viel im Homeoffice
gearbeitet haben, die haben ja oftmals
keine optimalen Arbeitsplätze gehabt, weil sie irgendwo am Küchentisch saßen
oder irgendwo auf der Bettkante mit ihrem Computer auf dem Knie
und die haben dann eben hinterher
gemerkt, mir tun die Schultern, der Nacken weh und ich habe
Rückenschmerzen. Zu Corona fällt mir noch eine wichtige Sache ein
im Zusammenhang mit Mononukleose.
Man sagt, dass Leute,
die tatsächlich diese Mononukleose hatten,
ein höheres Risiko haben, an Long Covid
zu erkranken. Also,
da scheint es irgendwie so eine Korrelation zu geben,
dass diese Gruppe tatsächlich gefährdet ist.
Ja, normalerweise diese
infektiose Mononukleose mit MS,
es gibt eine Verbindung, aber ich weiß nicht,
Covid und infektiose Mononukleose gibt es eine.
Manchmal für Immunschwäche oder andere Probleme.
Ja, ich denke, das hat mit Immunschwäche dann irgendwas zu tun.
Okay,
ich denke mal so viel für heute Abend für Sie.
Vielen, vielen Dank auch.
Wir sehen uns jetzt wieder
heute in 14 Tagen, nein, gar nicht, weil Dienstag in 14 Tagen.
Ich bin jetzt eine ganze Woche weg,
bin aber am Dienstag in einer Woche
wieder zu Hause, da können wir wieder eine Anamnese machen.
Vielen Dank.
Im April glaube ich.
Das ist dann schon der 1. April, genau.
Nein, der 31. ist der
Dienstag.
31. März.
Gut, und da können wir wieder machen,
da bin ich wieder zu Hause.
Jetzt wünsche ich Ihnen allen erstmal ein total schönes und entspanntes
Zuckerfest oder Fest des Fastenbrechens, wie auch immer.
Haben Sie schöne Tage und lassen Sie es sich gut gehen.
Seien Sie froh über alles, was gut ist auf der Welt.
Und hoffen wir mal, dass es besser wird für Sie alle und für uns alle.
Tschüss zusammen, ich wünsche Ihnen alles, alles Gute und heute einen schönen Abend.
Vielen, vielen Dank.